There are a lot of horror movies that are
best seen just once.
But every now and again a movie comes along
that's not only rewatchable, but enjoying
it a second or third time is necessary to
get the full experience.
Here are some all-time classic horror flicks
definitely worth screening again and again.
The Guest
Boasting killer performances by Dan Stevens
and Maika Monroe, The Guest features a mysterious
young man showing up on a family's doorstep
claiming to have served in the military with
their recently-deceased son.
He quickly becomes integral to their family
dynamic, but the children suspect he may be
hiding something.
Between the stunning cinematography and ratcheting
levels of intensity, The Guest is one of those
rare horror films that allows it tersest moments
to linger just beyond your expectation until
it reaches its intense climax.
It's worth revisiting over and over both as
a study in effective genre experimentation
and for the sheer fun of the central performances
of the film.
The Shining
To say that The Shining is director Stanley
Kubrick's magnum opus is a discredit to the
other films in his unparalleled catalogue,
but it's certainly one of his finest works.
Adapted from the Stephen King novel of the
same name, The Shining is a cinematic titan
— every frame is significant.
Featuring Kubrick's signature visual flair,
a career-best performance by Jack Nicholson,
and a multitude of thematic ideas and elements,
it's a layered film that benefits from multiple
viewings largely due to how much there is
to interpret.
From the ambiguous ending to the larger concepts
being explored amid all the jump scares, this
movie will rank highly on any film school
syllabus for generations to come.
The House of the Devil
It's tough for a film to strike a good balance
between being fun and being genuinely frightening,
and it takes a director with a deft hand to
pull it off, but Ti West managed it with The
House of the Devil.
A modern throwback to horror cinema of the
'70s and '80s, the film has the familiar premise
of a babysitting gig gone wrong, but tells
the story better than it's been handled in
ages.
Thanks to its grainy aesthetic, it feels like
an authentic film from the era, but it diverts
from the norm in its lack of reliance on jump
scares or plot contrivances and instead plays
out in a slow-burn fashion, paying off in
a horrifying finale.
Yes, it's partially worth revisiting just
to see how much of the ending is telegraphed
early on, but it's also just an old-fashioned
good time.
It's the kind of movie you want to show to
friends who have never heard of it just to
see their reactions.
A Nightmare on Elm Street
Wes Craven's original A Nightmare on Elm Street
still works, even all these years later.
Don't let the countless lousy sequels distract
you from the fact that Freddy Krueger's first
cinematic outing is funny, engaging, and scary
to boot.
When a group of friends realize they're all
having the same dream about a scarred man
with knives for fingers coming after them,
they find themselves being pursued by a killer
that exists in the world of dreams but is
still capable of causing plenty of damage
in the real world.
The frights are just as potent as they were
decades ago, and some of the effects will
still leave viewers wondering how the filmmakers
pulled them off on such a small budget.
A Nightmare on Elm Street is essential viewing,
and few slasher films have aged as well as
this one.
(maniacal laughter)
Phantasm
Shot in disjointed bits and pieces over the
course of a year, 1979's Phantasm still came
together as one of the most memorable horror
movies of all time.
But the film's difficult shoot may have actually
helped make it so memorable.
Phantasm, more than any other horror movie,
captures the feeling of a nightmare perfectly.
There's an off-tilt flow to it.
Not everything makes perfect sense, but in
the moment you don't question the film's logic.
And there's a strong undercurrent of trauma
and grief present in the plot.
The film's surreal narrative focuses on three
teens being pitted against a sinister mortician
known only as The Tall Man.
It's a bizarre movie that really should not
work on any level.
But it does.
And the result is one of the coolest horror
films ever made.
The Thing
John Carpenter's The Thing stands out as a
masterpiece because it's steeped in paranoia,
tension, and dread.
The film follows a group of researchers in
a secluded base in the arctic who come into
contact with a shapeshifting alien.
Trapped in a small bunker with nowhere to
run and no way to get help, the men find themselves
pitted against one another, never sure if
any individual crew member is who they say
they are.
It is, note for note, a perfect horror film.
All of the performances are strong, and the
gruesome practical effects haven't aged a
day since the film's release.
And it becomes more interesting with every
screening as its subtle details and nuances
become more and more evident.
The Cabin in the Woods
There's a sad reality even the most die-hard
fans of horror will cop to: for every great
horror film there's a dozen that are awful.
That's why The Cabin in the Woods was such
a shot of adrenaline to the genre when it
first hit theaters.
It turned horror on its head and reminded
fans that they deserve better.
Director Drew Goddard and writer Joss Whedon
wrote what they called a "loving hate letter"
to the genre, demanding the death of the old
ways and the initiation of new blood in horror
filmmaking.
They wanted something different, original,
and thoughtful, and in their demands for change
they gave viewers just that.
It's the sort of film that offers something
new for viewers to discover, no matter how
many times they've seen it.
Be it jokes that went unnoticed before or
homages to classic horror flicks, there's
always something that will stick out on a
rewatch.
Horror films are rarely this intelligent,
funny, or easy to come back to.
Halloween
Sometimes you just need the original, and
while it certainly wasn't the first horror
film, John Carpenter's Halloween is very much
a movie that defined the modern horror scene.
Everything present in the genre today, from
story structure to individual horror movies
spawning multi-film franchises can be traced
back to Halloween.
And even decades after its original run, it
still hasn't aged a day.
Carpenter made Halloween on a shoestring budget
and couldn't rely on special effects or flashy
trickery to make his movie work.
Even with those limitations, beginning to
end, it's a perfect horror movie.
It has everything a great horror flick needs,
from the occasional laugh to relieve the tension
to the compelling villain viewers would never
want to cross.
Every generation of genre enthusiast eventually
comes back to Halloween, and that probably
won't ever change.
New horror movies and franchises come and
go, but Halloween is eternal for a reason.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!